let's talk about canceled culture
because you were telling me a story it
you want to just tell me the story about
what's going on with this this this
friend of yours or this colleague yeah
and I can't I really can't get into too
many details but what I can tell you is
that I have a colleague who's a
clinician he has a professional license
like me professional license takes a
long time to get and so as he's a it's a
little different licensing that he has
slightly different profession but it
takes still takes a long time to get a
long time to build up a set of clients
and a life and a profession and
apparently there are some people who
have no relationship to him who have
decided that they don't like what they
think he is you know they think he's a
racist they thinks he's and massages
nothing could be further from the truth
he's the nicest guy in the world but
they've decided that he needs to be
cancelled so they spent probably out of
20 minutes trying to destroy what he has
spent a lifetime building and his
license is under legitimate threat well
he has to defend this and you know I'm
watching this situation I know it's not
an isolated situation I expect my
license to come under attack maybe
because of something I said today well
at some point I'm gonna be under
attacking and I'm pretty
I shouldn't tempt fate I'm pretty anti
fragile like I right yeah I'm leaning
into it lean into it
I don't care yeah I've already decided
that I will make a spectacle of it when
my license so I'm in a way a little part
of me is looking forward to it and I
shouldn't probably say that out loud
but anyway I'm thinking about these
people who are trying to destroy this
man's life because they're trying to
destroy his livelihood they're they're
going after his family essentially by
taking away that livelihood and I'm
thinking what would I say to these
people if I could say one thing - and
the thing that I would say is nobody
likes you nobody and I don't say that to
be mean it's actually kind of a pathetic
situation in a heartbreaking situation
because obviously the people that are
under threat of being cancelled by them
don't like these people but even their
own side quote unquote their own side
does exactly because like JK Rowling
what happens when they step out of line
well they get savaged and what happens
if they stop looking for people to
pursue and then destroy because it's not
enough that you destroy one person it's
not enough that you rein on one parade
you have to keep the hatred coming so
what's the end game to this you're 85
years old
someday you're looking back on what a
trail of destruction all the things that
you broke and all the people that you
heard and and the opportunity that you
squandered to have maybe build something
that other people might find useful and
in the bigger sense what what are you
trying to build here do you want your
children growing up in this totalitarian
state cuz you're not gonna be in charge
I know you're not gonna be charged here
mean but you're not mean enough no but
they don't they don't get it and so I'll
actually go back to the first thing you
said that they think he's a racist or
whatever no they don't they don't you
rahein you're right they don't thing and
you're exactly right they don't think
he's a racist they just want to destroy
yeah so they've they've seen weakness
and an opportunity to attack they've
tried coming for me but sorry I'm I'm a
crazy person like you literally nothing
you can do
so they thirst for that reaction and for
that opportunity it is kind of weird who
they target and why they target though
yeah like I wonder why you know some
people who are random nobodies who make
a bad tweet have their entire lives
destroyed yeah but like you you
literally you know write a book about
the tactical guide to women and you know
people kind of shrug their soldiers
shoulders and most guys actually give a
positive you know view of it why haven't
they tried to I don't want to put you on
the spot but like they haven't come for
you but they've come for some random due
to made a bad tweet yeah it's almost
meaningless I don't get it
meaningless yes so what are they not
seeing in me or what are they seeing in
the other person weakness kind of
mystifying you're not weak they know
that you'll make a spectacle of it
you'll lean into it you'll be empowered
by it and so they do nothing no I'll let
you know next week when I will see what
happens but do you want to get attacked
do you know who count dank EULA is yes I
met koundak you thanks awesome yeah he's
a he's a he's a smart regular guy
couldn't understand a word he said but
he told me a good story so what's what's
funny is when they first went after him
the actual government and the police
because he made that pug video mmm it
made him made him famous for better or
for worse yeah and he's gone on to make
similar jokes and other videos and now
they don't and I think it's because they
realized he's empowered by it
yeah it's not having the reaction they
want they want the knee bent they want
people to say yes I'm sorry I'm sorry
they wanna they want a scalp for their
you know for
wall they went a notch on their bedpost
for lack of a better analogy they wanna
they want to show that we have power and
will win he was a failure for them he's
exceeded yeah I mean look I want to be
fair I think a lot of his life was was
really messed up and yes it was a
miserable experience for him yeah yeah
very mixed bag because he didn't get the
fame but but here's the thing what I did
to him was unconscionable so I think the
reason why you know I don't I don't want
to pretend like he's not going through
anything still cuz I don't know a lot
about what his personal life is like but
he's got him to make some some edgy
jokes since then and the question is why
not again why don't they go after him
again that's a really good question but
I think I know I think I know too well
why do you think you have my friend Jack
Murphy on here a few weeks ago Jack
Murphy is the poster child for how to
handle canceled culture they canceled
him he came back a thousand times
stronger yeah exactly that's how you
handle and so did dank yep and so I look
at Jack and dank EULA as confident and
strong men who you know whatever you
want to say about them look it looked at
what was in front of them weathered the
storm and said now I'm gonna you know
it's it's like what the saying you can't
control the one but you can adjust your
sails so when they were faced with this
it was bad yeah but they've turned it
into something positive for themselves
for all the bad that came with it
yeah they both gone through very dark
times because of this and but it came
out the other side they came out the
other side and in in you know I want to
be careful of this because I want to be
disrespectful but I think in some ways
they've they've done really well because
of it they've been able to use it as an
example or it's it's allowed them to
become people who can speak as to what
this is and why it's bad and they've
become you know to an extent public
figures which is you know they've built
something from it I think the reason
they don't come back for them is because
it it's bad for what they want mm-hmm
they don't want someone to come back and
succeed it proves they have no power
yeah they want to cancel you and they
want you to go away forever so that they
can keep having this weird fringe cult
like group of people succeed and expand
and grow and if you know what they
haven't thought about but ya know they
don't like it's a chaotic destructive
force so like you know what I've been
seeing with there was this chart I was
looking at of the the voters for the
2016 election and what was interesting
is that Donald Trump's
bass was evenly split economically
between left and right mmm like
strangely there were socialist Trump
supporters very very rare very rare and
I want to pretend and act like he's a
large group but there was this grid
showing left-to-right economics like
liberal to conservative and Trump's base
was you know even but one thing they
were opposed to was identity politics
and so what was interesting to me about
that and I could be interpreting the
data wrong I won't act like I'm you know
I don't have to pull them in front of me
was that what it seems is there's a
group of people with no clear goals it's
all just pure chaos and destruction they
cancel people for random reasons they go
after some people are not others we
don't know why you know they just want
to get a scalp on their you know wall or
whatever yeah and one is never enough
then you got to get to Scouts right we
get three and it's like a game to them
yeah but but what that says to me is
it's not really about politics or
winning they can't win if at any point
and they can't win in the sense that we
actually give in to their demands that's
why no matter what happens they're
always the victim cuz that's part of the
chaos but anyway I'll move on from that
point and making you know another point
as to what you were saying why would
anyone want to live in that world
the totalitarian world that they are
constructing there if they were to get
it they would find out that they don't
want to live there it's over see Doctor
Strange everything that movie's long
time ago barely remember well yeah yeah
well so I love this movie and it reminds
me of to throw in some pop-culture
references the bad guy basically thinks
that there's this great you know if the
dark world comes in two hours and makes
as part of the one it's it's like in
eternal life oh I'm thinking dr.
Strangelove this is different movie I
didn't see this yeah yeah Doctor Strange
is that it's a 2016 it's uh so the bad
guy thinks if they let in the Dark
Dimension which would engulf the earth
they will all live forever and it's it's
eternal life but it's actually eternal
suffering
and so he's actively fighting for this
and in the end he sort of gets what he
wants and Doctor Strange is like you got
what you wanted to turn a life you're
not gonna like it it's like what these
people are fighting for right if they
really knew what they were gonna get
really wouldn't want it but but here's
the reason why I asked this is like I'm
thinking about what makes someone happy
fulfilled free and for me I'm like
I couldn't imagine waking up and being
miserable every day of always thinking
the world is evil always thinking you
can't save yourself you're pathetic
you're weak
it's very cult-like when they tell you
that you can't succeed you are being
oppressed by a system that can never be
changed so bend the knee and join the
hive join the swarm and attack anyone
who dare oppose us that's the only way
what kind of person wants to live in
that world I don't know I'll tell you
another book that I have I told you
about my 1949 injury a psychology book
another book that I have is I think the
most commonly used gender studies
textbook it's called women's voices
feminist visions or something like that
and it's about a hundred and five essays
all boiling down to the same thesis that
if you're a woman the world is trying to
make you miserable
so you read this book and you find all
the ways that the world is trying to
make you miserable why would you go past
chapter one
that's what mystifies me about this book
it's like the people who purposefully
read their Twitter mentions yeah I don't
do it I don't because it'd just be
policy if people saying nasty things all
the time not even to me to other people
to each other I'll tweet something and
then I go in there and it's someone's
like spot on Tim and then they'll insult
somebody and then someone will insult
them back I want to read that okay I
don't live in that world when I wake up
in the morning I think happy thoughts I
put a smile on my face I say I wonder
what's happening in the world today
that's gonna be fun
today is gonna be a good day today's
always a good day I never wake up
thinking I want to be sad or miserable
and I think part of this is you know
what I was told by my dad when I was
younger that some people like being
miserable and it sounds paradoxical but
it's it's true they they relish in being
upset and thinking there that nothing
can change they want to be in that
suffering so that it's easier for them
than accepting that they're just
pathetic people who can't solve their
own problems instead of saying to
yourself if I'm gonna succeed I need to
stand up and go work towards a goal you
can say it's not my fault I didn't do
anything wrong
and then just sit there in your misery
blaming everyone else for your problem
right I guess misery loves company so
they want to cancel people they want to
engulf you into their world
yeah well I think this is why Jordan
Peterson talks about responsibility
because your options are everything
matters or nothing matters and when
nothing matters you don't have to do
anything you can just sit there you
don't have to nothing you nothing you
will ever do will ever make any
difference so why would you bother and
and the alternative is terrifying
but it's much more meaningful there may
even be a bit of a neurological basis
for this because there have been studies
that that show that when a person is
ruminating in this sort of pain that the
I I don't like this loose terminology
but the reward circuit there's a very
sloppy terminology but there's there's a
little bit of dopamine hit that comes
with the chain and you can get into this
trap where you're in a sense addicted to
those little dopamine hips hits of being
miserable so maybe maybe that plays into
it also I don't know that's also just a
lazy way to go it's you know that's
probably the simplest explanation as
well I'm not responsible for anything so
I don't have to do anything
exactly it's easy to fall into a world
where you don't have to do anything yeah
and it's it's it's I don't know laziness
I don't know what it is I feel bad I
feel like everybody has potential yes I
think you know there's a mix of nature
and nurture in everyone's development
but I do think that everyone has the
potential to be successful if only we
told them they could and so you end up
with a lot of people who live in this
world of this woek ideology where
they're told unfortunately you can't
succeed because white people are
pressing you because men are oppressing
you because bankers because the global
elites whatever they want to say right I
can't stand it
nobody listen even if you are the most
oppressed person in the world you can
find a way yeah you know III don't wanna
be disrespectful but I always thought
Mugsy Bose was a pretty inspirational
you know I familiar with Mugsy famous
basketball player I think was in the
Charlotte Hornets and he's like 5 foot 3
oh right NBA player yeah because he said
I'm gonna do it nothing's gonna get in
my way
so I don't know a lot about him I mean
that was you know I was a real little
kid back in in his era in the NBA but I
remember you know people often talk
about how if you want to be in the NBA
guys you gotta be seven feet tall no
that's not true some people you know
have just pushed the limits and said no
way it's mine I'll take it you gotta be
seven feet tall or you got to have
something that compensates for not being
seven feet tall yeah
and he provided that value and he could
do crazy good 360 dunk like that's like
he was jumping his entire body height
like this that that's that's that's
inspiration to me yeah that you can you
can look in the face of everyone telling
you it'll never happen and you can say
watch me so this is the ultimate tragedy
of the canceled cultures all of these I
don't think it's a lot of people it's a
small group of people and and what
wasted potential all this energy you're
putting toward tearing something down
you could be putting toward creating
something useful that's so sad maybe
it's just uh a pendulum swing and equal
and opposite reaction
it's the chaotic force of entropy and
our social behavior is coming back to
haunt us what do you think is gonna
happen is cancel culture gonna go away I
don't know I don't know I don't know
maybe I think what when you see people
like Dave Chappelle Joe Rogan Ricky
Gervais cetera all just saying shut up
you don't care
eventually you're powerless yeah that's
why I was saying like I think they
stopped going after you know dank EULA I
think that's why the stop going after
Jack and now it's like when they find
their power didn't work and they've come
back it's like uh-oh it's like if you
know you you tried to go after somebody
thinking this strategy will work it
doesn't and now you have no idea what to
do next you better just back off and
leave and go try somewhere else right
it's like a burglar truck coming to your
house trying to break the door and you
show up with a gun they run away your
door broke you got to go through the
problem call you know pasta calling the
police it's probably your family scared
so it is it bad for you the guy's not
coming back right they'll go to the
other house when you punch the bully in
the nose metaphorically speaking I'm mad
at violence no it's not when you hit
someone in the back of head of the bike
lock it's when you give that
metaphorical punch to the nose you've
helped the bully understand where the
limits are you know what though it's not
even about winning against the bully now
watch him in the nose no it's about
setting up a boundary and so for me it
was oh my attitude was always like I
will burn this ship to the ground before
you win yeah even if I go down with it
know that before you start a flight and
so even then it's kind of like I'm gonna
avoid that guy yeah you want to find a
victim go find somebody else yes thanks
for checking out this segment from the
Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
every Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you